today's topic since you want to talk
about ukraine i don't oh yeah i was
about to propose you that video i was
about to promote bro wrong i was about
to propose you that video dear president
vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
stop this is not how the human brain
functions there's some people that have
been having some crappy lives crappy
mothers crappy fathers they became they
became amazing human beings and there
are some people that had everything they
needed in the world
two loving parents
what they become
crackheads
crackheads like crack kids [ __ ] i'm not
talking about [ __ ] up like not even
just cracking cracking is the thing but
i'm talking about they became [ __ ] up
yo shout out to white women
thinking you're going to change the
world what's
the only ones who [ __ ] see a dictator
thinking about inflicting genocide i'd
be like if you were just held as a baby
imagine what you're saying she looks at
poutine and you're like oh look at this
man
if only i had breastfed him
hey
have a little bit of teddy never with
the stories plight the world unfurled
before our eyes a pure demise of nations
sitting peaceful under a night sky if i
was your mother the world would have
been warm
so much see my issue with white women
saying stuff like this like [ __ ] you
breed school shooters
all these warm embraces that you was
talking about but you out here making
school shooters
huh what happened
come on down b if i could have held you
in my arms the way we would have stopped
each other from bearing arms under the
beautiful night sky you would have known
that your eyes in the pie please
understand that you are loved the way
that you are hugged i will show you a
warm embrace make sure that you will
never have to brace for war stop stop
stop all the fighting the conflict is
bad no i do not want to see any more of
the children sad
boy my boy poutine i love you son i want
you to know that you will always be
loved what am i saying bro what is this
what's supposed to happen
i don't know those are some parts
she did that [ __ ] she filmed that [ __ ]
yeah and then she was like i'mma post
that [ __ ] you know this is like i'm
gonna change the world
yeah yeah this is like when people
posted that black square for black lives
matter this is a cringe the stain the
soul stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a cruel unjust world
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
of you
is this why you do not hide nor away shy
from taking back the world it was it
because so early in life all that strife
wrapped your little body with fear
if i was your mother if the world was
cold i'd have died to make you warm i'd
have died to protect you from the unjust
the violence the terror the uncertainty
i would have died to give you life oh
dear mr president putin
if only i'd been your mother
perhaps the torture of unwritten youth
would not within your heart and view a
scripture to such fealty against that
world that you thought was so cruel
perhaps you would but you know this
makes me think of this makes me think of
like uh we are the world all the
hollywood actors it's that same level of
cringe these people are just
disconnected
right they're so in their art bubble and
everyone's been jerking them off saying
you're the hottest [ __ ] since sliced
bread i remember i've seen her in this
tv i think it's like beverly hills
i think so something like that right and
it's just like when you grow up when you
when you work on these kinds of sets you
get like an instagram following you get
a following everybody telling you're
wonderful you go to press events
everyone's giving you cake everyone's
showing you so much love and so you
start to buy into your own hype you
think like beyond acting you're an
amazing person as well right because we
will sign you up oh we're doing this
campaign where we're gonna save all the
cheetahs would you like to join
i'd love to lend my voice to your
campaign let's make a change i'm a good
person yo thanks
i don't know about that person i don't
know that person well most of us human
beings all right
it's like
you know what they're my favorite thing
to say when people come up to me and
they
they flip out
you know what my favorite thing is what
i ain't [ __ ] calm down that's it calm
down these people are just out of town
calm down
i love you so much don't [ __ ] that's a
lot you love the idea of me you don't
know me
okay
stop stop i ain't [ __ ] i'm just a human
[ __ ] being okay if you keep this [ __ ]
up i could slap you the [ __ ] right now
stop
stop but i think your problem is that if
she was your mother you wouldn't be
coming with so much aggression i
understand the passion that which you
come with the success of thoughts and
the words stop you say stop but when are
you gonna say go stop drop and roll the
way that we stay
with the issues
i ain't gonna lie
oh god like that [ __ ] was fire not even
yeah yeah [ __ ] low-key that [ __ ] was
fine yeah yeah i'm inspired i could see
that when i have a caucus queen just
bring mars to me
yes
because we got our nubian princesses but
my [ __ ] is queens i feel like this is
[ __ ] christ but i'm happy that this
i'm happy that people are like yo this
is [ __ ] cringe this is cringe
it's cringe it's it it tells me yo you
want to change your [ __ ] dictator
with your love it's just like it screams
like um but you know i love him i'm
going to change him i'm able to change
him he's a good i know he's a good man
he's a good man if only i could nurture
him
oh shut up
shut up
god
this is bigger than this and that's not
how life works
okay bad mothers and bath fathers don't
necessarily
do psychopaths sometimes it's more
complicated than that there's some
disney rinky dink ass cars pixar movie
[ __ ] that's not what it is
it's not like only that gun and there's
the bad that's not how it works that's
not now none of this works the brain is
a complex [ __ ] [ __ ] sometimes love
and hugs don't solve [ __ ]
it's more complicated than that
but if i was your mother oh shut up
shut up
[ __ ]
i think it's a strong reflection of how
out of touch the elite and the media are
from the regular person right especially
these folks on hollywood or these folks
that are living the arts and making all
this money like they just lose touch
with what people go through right that's
why they think if they take a picture of
themselves feeding some homeless dude
with a sandwich they've done a real
change right or they sing we are the
world when shit's going on and they
think like oh this is oh this is what we
needed you know what i'm saying so i
think it's just a reflection of that and
that's why i cringe so hard when this
happened but you're never going to stop
seeing this because so long as people
live in their bubbles and they're told
their opinions are important they're
always going to give takes that are out
of touch this is the equivalent this
girl is the equivalent of a man
watching someone fight and be like nah
nah nah nah nah b
nah because if it was me if it was me i
just go you know
papa people in fights that imagine
themselves fight
are 2000 less 2 000
less effective than what really would
happen okay you're not but you go there
on site and you deal with the
circumstances and you prob it's a
possibility that you would have dealt
worse than that no not because i would
not be
nah
so you going in there being like if i
was the nabi i'm not buying it but it's
not about the the the size of the fight
in the dog
it's about the size of the love in the
fighter if you would have been fed with
more love you would have been capable of
fighting for what you love
there's a parallel between the amount of
heart that you have
that comes from within and from without
me form a community a bond in which we
might constantly offer you protection a
form of conduct to the world's illness
you need that protection like winter on
a winter coat you need to know that
you're protected for the elements but
capable of striving through them bro
yes like an inuit passing through the
antarctica man you just haven't really
resistance that's higher than the
average
so the question now becomes
are you willing to fight but more
importantly are you willing to love love
those close to you love those far from
you but constantly coming through with
love
spread those emotions out like doves
flying through the night sky
savate
give me some
appreciate that
but
just want to cover this if you guys want
to hear our takes on ukraine i don't
really have much to be honest with you
oh yo if you want to have a take on
ukraine what's going on go see the news
outlets there's a bunch of [ __ ] i ain't
got nothing more to say and what's going
on i'm not sure i understand fully
what's going on and i swear to god i
looked at this thing from different
angles and i'm like i i i'm you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] i don't know
there's a lot i'm looking at this i'm
like oh
there's a lot of [ __ ] i don't comprehend
so don't come to me for the take there's
other people that's going to give you
the take i'm not the one i'm not about
to start a geopolitics i don't know what
natural resources are involved i don't
know the history i
honestly don't care to learn so i'm
gonna let other people who have far more
curiosity package it and then put it out
there because it's not for me so all the
people are asking us for this take i'm
like i don't know i don't know just when
i saw this video and i thought it was
cringe as hell so i just
super cringe yeah yeah people are like
watching live streams of kiev just like
waiting for like russia to invade and
you're realizing one thing that's really
weird it's like they've turned war into
entertainment are we yes
yes
instagram
just broadcast that [ __ ] life to be fair
though what's the broadcasting is just
fake
all the stuff the broadcast like go take
clips from like 2012 of like somebody
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they'll take it if you watch the news
the news is also going like these are
not confirmed facts they'll be like this
amount of people died yeah so when it
comes to these kind of things a lot of
propaganda there's a lot of lies out
there so sifting through it is not the
easiest thing
i'm just saying i just think it's
fascinating this is the first time in
history where war has been turned into
entertainment yeah man people
folks are live streaming though you'll
put a one in the chat if you're sad for
kiev because
you put a one in the chat if you're all
like what the [ __ ] is this
people are like dying live right now you
just like put a two in the chat for the
russians i'm like
that's math trying to work with the
algorithm yeah put a one rough bruh
but i mean yeah it is what it is it's
i'm not yeah and i've looked at it yeah
i look i research a bit
whoa i'm like that black guy
but anyways let us know what you guys
think about here